uh here's Steve Bannon with what appears
to be a crazy moment I believe that's a
doll that a wizard brought to life if
I'm not mistaken
just Kellyanne calm a lot of people
don't know this but she is a former Hot
Dog on a Stick employee she worked there
growing up as a child in her local mall
and she honors them today with this
great hot dog in this outfit oh well
IIIi don't they I think if we made the
not winner she ran a tough campaign
great campaign they they thought they
had it and we here and here we are as
Donald Trump the the host of The
Apprentice and billionaire is is about
to be smaller than you know Paul Ryan
making his way in
yeah Paul Ryan gym rat loves the gym
great body and I you know I'm purely
heterosexual but Paul Ryan has
unbelievable body great biceps he loves
a sleeveless shirt does really and I
love him in him I really do I love him
in them I've always said that I love him
in them I would him if I yes Dick
Cheney you could see him there again who
does look like well he's getting ready
penguin
getting a cowboy makeover he's about to
shed his skin he will well it's got to
be tough too if you're him because those
wings are probably itching at the flesh
I'm ready to bust those out and just
take off could you imagine having big
huge black wings having you sit there
strapped down first down take off again
you there was you'll see the action of
the wizard he's supposed to be around
130 but doesn't he give a speech before
he does the it's not a speech it's a
rhyming chant no but he does like it
comes out and he goes
and now for hell on earth if Anita no no
no but he's more he's more bobble Bobble
toil travel I will turn the town to
Ravel
you know and then it's like and then
he's got power and his staff and he's
pointing it at things that things are
exploding as Donald Trump sort of
consumes the light of the Sun and the
rays that are coming out of this sheds
his human form and swings Cheney's wings
spring out and he flies into the dark
bloody sky as Trump starts emitting fire
and realizes now we can use all this new
power he's usurp for evil or whatever he
wants okay so I'm getting this in
apparently Putin was out on his balcony
jerking off oh that's weird I must say I
got a refresh confirmed yeah he is